okay i think we are getting very close
to being able to sort of close the door
proverbially and maybe at some point a
literal door uh on my pillow ceo and
founder mike lindell
he actually quote testified before the
louisiana
senate committee
looking at
i guess voter fraud it's the voting
system commission they were exploring
voter fraud
and he very quickly imploded and tried
to cite some kind of weird data that he
has access to which proves based on an
investigation of votes that he did
that it's all fraudulent and trump won
or whatever and the thing you have to
remember is does he even have ac aside
from does the data or do the data show
what he claims
does pillow even have access to such
data and it's not a question we actually
have an answer to but here's a little
bit of his testimony for lack of a
better term last thing i'll say is our
overseas votes this is where they were
going to and when you say computers you
want to know the next era emailing and
and uh texting in your vote right now
you say that could never happen right
all of our military was almost 97 were
emailed in from overseas and their
families
all of them that we found so far were
for biden
and that's our overseas military class
so that's a pretty big claim we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines
okay so what does he mean by
investigated votes since he doesn't
really have access to that information
but this is not a new claim the the
claim that he's making is
we've investigated overseas votes
and they were all for biden which
doesn't make sense it just doesn't that
you would expect to see some trump votes
this has been claimed before
the claim is specific to georgia and
it's if you look at georgia military
overseas ballots
they were all for biden and thus it's
evidence of voter fraud this was widely
investigated early in 2021
this conspiracy theory website called
the gateway pundit made a similar claim
saying quote in georgia
a sample now this is a key word a sample
of military ballots were reviewed
recently and all went for joe biden
there's no way these were legit so the
first question is is it true that all
the overseas military ballots in georgia
were for biden and the answer is no
notice that the gateway pundit uses this
phrase a sample of overseas ballots
this was investigated and what they
found is that there are some batches of
votes
that were all biden votes so for example
there was a batch of 130 ballots
those were all biden and there's a
reason for that they had already been
sorted by candidate so think about the
the way that this worked the ballots
come in massive dumps of ballots as all
of you guys know about
you go okay
we're gonna put the biden ballots in one
box
and we're gonna put the trump ballots in
another box so you sort them and you've
got a box of all biden ballots you hand
that box to someone to review and they
go hey every single one of these is for
biden it must be fraud as they like to
say well no it's just they were
correctly sorted and you're looking at a
biden box of ballots so it makes sense
that if they were correctly sorted that
they would all be biden the georgia
secretary of state's office
did a hand recount of those they were
able to quote uphold and reaffirm the
original outcome there were two other
audits done of georgia's results
including looking at 15 000 absentee
ballots there was no evidence of
widespread fraud if i do an initial sort
and it's correct and then you review the
sort you would anticipate that you would
have a large tranche of trump boxes
and a large tranche of biden boxes
that's all that happened here and the
claims are now starting to be at
starting the they've always been absurd
but the claims are now so transparently
toothless there's nothing there
that my expectation is in the next four
months particularly as we get closer to
the midterms that the pillow stuff is
going to wind down once you're beyond
the midterms and even the people who
believe this stuff are starting to think
you know mike
it might not all be just about to come
out in a blockbuster way
i think you'll see a dramatic reduction
in the amount we hear from pillow i
could be wrong but at least that's me
optimistically thinking